well just like the rest of 2020
thanksgiving is shaping up to be just a
little bit different
our joe moeller spoke to las vegas
visitors and locals who shared their
plans
my whole entire family is coming over
last minute grocery shoppers say this is
not the average turkey day we're all
going to have our mask on still
even though we're family yeah
because one of our cousins are sick so
we're just going to protect her the cdc
was recommending small gatherings of two
households or less
and to consider virtual celebrations
usually we have a lot of family coming
out
people say family is still getting
together but simply not as much or just
locals you know you got to be safe
do it you know do what you're asked to
do we want to end this thing
so you know you have to cooperate
nationwide millions traveled by car
or by plane aaa expected a 10 drop in
travel
tourists who made their way to vegas to
celebrate the holiday notice the strip
is different this year
in vegas itself it's still pretty busy
but like i guess like
there's not like the shows and stuff
going on we found plenty of visitors at
the welcome to las vegas sign
thanksgiving day
people say they are happy to still be
able to travel just enjoy
the shopping the casinos and
all the things that vegas can offer us
as virus concerns linger many still say
they are taking kobe seriously
we are taking lots of precautions and
we think it's important to have the
masks and we got tested like the day
before we traveled
and like are going to test again as soon
as we get back to new york
people are hopeful next year will be
different and family can gather like
normal
hopefully it with the vaccine they got
coming out is going to help
help change that maybe next next giving
we'll all be together again
reporting in las vegas joe moeller 8
news now